hello everyone those of you who follow
chess regularly probably already know
this those of you who aren't so regular
maybe don't know that Ukrainian
Grandmaster animals eat ruck one - 2016
both the rapid championship and the
blitz Championship held in Qatar Doha
she won the world rapid championship
without losing a single game with seven
wins zero defeats and five draws and in
the blade section he owned she only lost
one game so in the entire 2016 world
rapid endless championship she only lost
one game so quite an achievement and
this year she was supposed to defend her
title both in blitz and rapid but
unfortunately she is not attending this
event held in Saudi Arabia now why isn't
she attend attending as she herself said
on her Facebook page she does not wish
to play chess in a country where women
are treated as secondary creatures as
she says I will put a link with the
entire article in the description below
so you can check it out
but for this video I prepared for you a
game played between animals eat chicken
and Natalia Zuko and Italia suka is also
a ukrainian Grandmaster this game was
played in round one of the World
Championship in 2016 in Qatar Doha and
animosity has the black pieces so let's
see what we are missing by not having an
ax in this world rapid Hamlet's
championship
Natalya plays d4 and Anna or plays
Knight to f6
so starting with Indian game and we have
C for g6 Knight to f3 and Bishop to g7
III and Anna castles we have Bishop to
e2 d6 Knights the c3 and the Knight B to
d7 through clock castles we have E 5
Queen to c2 rook to e8 and rook to e1 c6
by Musa choke and here are quite a lot
of options for white going for some
exchanges with D captures on e5 h3 is
certainly an option B 3
Natalia in this position plays B for
knife to f8 and by Musa choke and the
bishop to be to e4 now grabbing that
central square and killing them
right off of f3 Knight to d2 and now
Bishop to a5 nice to be three we have
rocked the c8 and Queen to d2 and here
d5 rook a to C 1 this is the best move
h5 and the Muslim starts expanding on
the Kings side we have a 4h for now and
h3 preventing that pawn from being
pushed even further Knight h2 a knight a
to h7 and the b5 now we have D captures
on c4 Bishop Bishop captures on c4 and
and Knight to g5 and here B captures on
c6 bite Zhukova and already here Medici
has the option of capturing on h3
because sorry if you can see this
relationship between the king the queen
and this night on g5 it's a very nice
relationship this night if it ever came
to f3 it will be very unfortunate for
white so Bishop captures on h3 is
definitely an option even in this
position but musici first recaptures on
c6 and this is this is still a better
position for black still the bed the
threat of Bishop captures on h3 is there
and it's very hard to say how white
should proceed here probably a move like
Queen to e2 to get the Queen out of that
awkward square but Tripoli gets a
different idea she plays d5 and she
meets Bishop captures on h3 with D
captures on c6 now offering to exchange
Queens mazda2 of course declines this
Queen to e7 and we have night to d4 now
rook eat the d8 now pinning this knight
on d4 and f4 and this f4 is definitely
the move that shouldn't have been played
after this f4 move things are really
going downhill for for to Cola mojo
captures each character's on f3 on
Poisson and there really isn't a good
move here G captures on h3 was played if
you play something like G captures on f3
simply rook captures on d4 and white is
lost it doesn't matter if you recapture
with the pawn or with the Queen Knight
captures on f3 will fork the Queen
whether she's on d2 or on d4 Africa
capturing the rook so after it captures
on f3 g captures on h3 was played but
now comes and even and even an even
greater idea f2 this comes with check
and unfortunately this pawn cannot be
captured if you play King captures on f2
here comes Knight G to e4 check you can
capture the night once but then the
other night will capture on e4 as well
this comes with check for King the king
and queen white loses the Queen and the
game and after f2 if you could play
Queen captures and have to then the
immediate knife captures on h3 again
Forks the king and the Queen you lose
the Queen and the game
so after this f2 move if you play King
f1 or King h1 you can always capture the
rock with with check you promote to a
queen so King to g2 was played and now
again was it you can it can capture the
rook anyone promotes to a knight and
this will also come with tempo but there
is no hurry
she plays Knight f2 e for this comes
with a temple on the Queen now this
Knight is also attacked by the rook by
the bishop the pawn on f2 is not
protected by the night and there really
isn't anything for black for white to do
here you could recapture once but the
other night comes to e4 doesn't really
change anything
Queen to d2 was played and now comes F
captures on e1
promoting to a queen Queen captures and
Knight captures on c3 Queen to h4 now
and it really isn't a better move here
capturing the night it doesn't really
doesn't really give anything white so
after Queen to h4 here a lot of moves
are winning for for for black you can
you can capture on d4 you can pretty
much do anything but I must replace
Queen captures on e3 and again there is
really not nothing you can do here rook
captures on c3 was played if you capture
with the bishop then pretty much any
move again is winning for black using
capture on d4 you can capture rook on c1
everything works here so after Queen to
b3 rook captures on c3 was played and
now Queen captures on d4
another another interesting idea would
would have been Queen to d2 but like I
said pretty much any move is good for
black here after 92 simply rook e8 and
there is no defense
this night will be captured if you block
this simply queen capture some be to the
roof is hanging the night is still
attacked terrible position for white but
after erupt captures on c3 Musa Chuck
has another interesting idea she plays
Queen captures on d4 Queen captures on
g5 and now the simple Queen to d2 check
and in this position the Ukrainian
Grandmaster Natalia zhukova resigned the
game the king is in check the Queen is
hanging on g5 if you capture the Queen
which you pretty much have to if you
don't want to lose your queen on g5
after Queen captures rook captures this
is what check King has the move and now
the simple Bishop captures on c3 Bishop
captures in the rook to c2 you win
either the dark square bishop or the
logic light square bishop and you have a
completely winning game so after this
Queen to d2 check Natalya took or
resigned and this this is a beautiful
game from round 1 of the world rapid
championship 2016 in Qatar Doha by
Ukrainian Grandmaster Anna Musa took and
it's really it's really ashamed that
she's not playing in this championship
it's just a terrible thing so what I
want to know is like I said I will put a
link in the description below where you
can read more on this topic there is an
entire article there have you heard
about this have you heard about Ana have
you heard about why she isn't playing in
this championship and what are your
thoughts about this and everything in
general so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon